hello my name is amelia chong and i'm a
senior at holt high school in winterfell
missouri
i want to share with you my project
analyzing genes relating to reactive
oxygen species
and stylophora pistolata corals under
short-term thermal stress
climate change is causing corals to die
at a devastating rate
this process is the result of the
disruption of the symbiotic relationship
between corals and algae resulting in
coral bleaching
it is commonly believed that the
overproduction of reactive oxygen
species by the coral symbionts
is responsible for bleaching but titles
of this topic are still under
investigation
a better understanding of the
progression of ros production over time
in relation to other bleaching factors
could benefit future studies of coral
bleaching short-term thermal stress is
reversible for some coral speech
species which might indicate that the
widespread bleaching of light could be
reversible
but a more detailed study of this
ecological microsystem is needed to
understand what measures could be done
to stop
slow down or reverse this process
to undertake this project i reviewed
literature on research in this field
and found that the latest projects
utilized molecular signatures from
microarray and next generation
sequencing data to study this phenomenon
as a result i see that the current
understanding of ros is that it is
the trigger of bleaching and
specifically in this study is a result
of increased
temperature from 24 degrees celsius to
34 degrees celsius
over a 10-day period at the molecular
level
this steep increase in temperature leads
to a cascade of bleaching related
processes
in dinoflagellates in the coral itself
to understand this phenomenon
i wanted to collect raw sequencing data
that would allow me to analyze gene
expression patterns of genes related to
reactive oxygen species
and stylophoropistillatocoral under
short-term thermal stress
before i tell you about my analysis
there are several terms that you need to
know
personally i've been throwing around the
phrase reactive oxygen species or ros
but what are they ros are highly
reactive molecules that can cause death
uh cell damage or death if built up in
the cell ros are the cause of the next
term
oxidative stress which is the term for
when ros
build up in a system which in this case
is the coral and the coral is then
unable to
detoxify itself and repair the damage
caused by the ros
oxidoreductase is an enzyme that helps
to reduce oxygen into a less harmful
compound
and mitigates the overproduction of ros
and then after that we have log two fold
change which is which is the data that
i'm working with
this is a quantity that compares gene
expression values and can reveal
if a gene is up or down regulated
i went to the national center for
biotechnology information's gene
expression omnibus
and found 179 data sets related to the
to coral heat stress out of the 179 data
sets
18 described gene expression using
microarray or high throughput sequencing
gene expression studies
i collected eight data sets that are
relevant to my problem statement and
performed exploratory analysis
in the exploratory analysis i found that
samples could be separated by
temperature levels so i define my
hypothesis that there are genes that
will be up or down regulated
in low and high temperature environments
for a broad range of different corals
after exploring the data sets i selected
the data set gse477
taken from the publication gene
expression profile of heat stress
in the red sea coral styrofoam pistolata
by moore landau at all
in that study the stylophora pistol out
of coral are separated into four
different groups exposed to four
different temperatures
24 degrees celsius which is the control
and then the treatment groups 28 degrees
celsius
32 degrees celsius and 40 degrees
celsius which i will be referring to
as 28 32 and 34 respectively
and from that data set i search for
genes that are differentially expressed
with a threshold of 0.05 p
value and above 1.2 log-2 fold change
then i annotated for ontology function
with uniprot and filtered for genes
related to
bleaching for each sample group
comparison
using the gene ontology information i
search for the key terms oxidative
repair
and oxytocidal reductase the results
show a large increase in the amount of
differentially expressed genes from the
low to medium treatment temperatures
a small decrease in the amount of
differentially expressed genes from the
medium to high treatment temperatures
giving an indicator for what significant
change starts to happen in coral
bleaching
i conducted t-tests with a threshold
p-value of 0.05 to compare the results
of each treatment for each filter term
for the up for both upregulated and the
downregulated data sets
the results supported the observation of
a stark contrast between the number of
genes differentially expressed
from the 28 treatment groups compared to
the 34 32 and 34 treatment groups for
all the filter terms of the upregulated
genes
when comparing the 32 and 34 treatments
the only filter term that yielded a
p-value below 0.05
was oxidative when looking at the
down-regulated set of genes
the oxidative term had a significant
difference between
the 28 and 32 agreement treatment groups
as well as the 32 and 34 treatment
groups but not for the 28
versus the 34 treatment groups possibly
indicating that the oxidative related
responses for treatment groups
28 and 34 were similar to each other and
different from treatment 32.
none of the other comparisons of
downregulated genes displayed a
significant p-value
even though next-generation sequencing
provides a greater dynamic range for
studying gene expression
and allows for more accurate
measurements of gene expression changes
microarray data can be analyzed and used
more easily due to the lack of annotated
coral genomes and gene function
in literature additional factors like
genetic background of corals
prior prior exposure to short-term
thermal stress
additional microbes in the microbiome
and their influence on the algae and
corals are mentioned
the study did not consider these
additional factors additionally this
study
this particular study is only three to
five samples per condition so it's not
as comprehensive as i would like it to
be
in the article which produced this data
set the authors wanted to understand
gene pathways associated with heat
stress when i started my analysis i
already had
a specific question about the
relationship between the coral and algae
so i focus on a different aspect of the
overall response to the heat stress
both this study and the original study
found that reactions to heat just began
during the 32 treatment but the original
study found that the reactions intensify
significantly
with the 34 treatment while this study
showed a slight decrease in reactions
this variation in multiple and results
could be caused by multiple different
factors
firstly the original study took into
account all genes while this study only
focused on a specific group of genes
secondly any genes that could not be
annotated with uniprot were omitted from
the study
and lastly analysis for the study was
performed using excel rather than using
a more powerful analysis tool such as r
in the future i would like to use a good
reference gmo genome to annotate next
generation sequencing data so i can do
this analysis in
more in depth and with less possibility
for mistakes by not using excel
additionally i would like to incorporate
more variation in species
and look at genetic data and microbiome
data to show relationship between
multiple factors for biological
validation of my analysis
lastly i would like to look into
mechanics mechanistic studies
that look at coral oxidal reductase in
response to ros levels and algae